hello welcome back and we're going to be
looking at the Halloween Gambit the
Halloween Gambit is a very risky opening
it's one of the few or if any openings
that you sacrifice a piece within the
first four moves it's crazy so it just
starts very simple E4 E5 then Knight to
F3 Knight to C6 very simple stuff that's
attacking the pawn and then defending it
then white plays Knight to C3 seemingly
Pretty Natural not doing anything crazy
and then Knight to F6 comes and now this
next move is the Halloween Gambit we
have this four Knight
setup and now white sacrifices the
Knight Knight takes E5 this Knight is
completely hanging it's a totally free
Knight
but white is sacrificing the Knight
because white is saying all right you
can have my knight but I'm going to get
these two Pawns in the center and I'm
going to get to develop and Castle very
quickly so I'm going to have good
control of the center and have a lead in
development just totally dominating in
all the opening
principles so black has to be very
careful black is much better but
if you're not careful things can go
poorly very quickly for example you just
went back to C6 this seems pretty
natural but actually causes black a
little bit of trouble because after D5
the Knight has to move
again and if you move it somewhere like
E5 again and F4 comes and you lose a lot
of time moving this Knight around and
white is going to be able to Castle very
quickly and push these pawns down the
board try to take advantage of the fact
that your king is in the center and
theirs will not be so this can be very
dangerous um it's probably still
holdable for black but it's very risky
there's a lot of ways you could go wrong
so instead of Knight to C6 here it's
actually better to bring the Knight to
G6 where it's not going to be kicked
around right
away and after Knight to G6 white likes
to kick our other Knight around they
can't play D5 to kick this one out so
they're going to play E5 and kick this
one out so unfortunately here our Knight
is really low on squares can't go here
or here because of this Knight is
covering those squares and then I can't
go here or here because the queen is
covering those squares so unfortunately
we have to undevelop we have to bring
our Knight back to its starting Square
and it's not a happy move to
make white uh should be pretty happy
seeing his opponent set his pieces back
up for the next game
but black does have a lot of counter
chances in return so let's see how this
can continue after Knight to G8 white
might play Bishop to C4 so bringing the
bishop towards the center getting ready
to Castle next turn and after this move
we're going to play a very common move
we've seen this move against pretty much
any Gambit um any of these counter
aggressive openings videos we've seen
this move it's
D5 so D5 in this position is a pawn
sacrifice we just need it to get some
space to get room for pieces to get out
so D5 completely hangs this Pawn it's
it's not defense Ed he can just totally
take it like this um but first let's
look at a few other options for white so
if white were a om assant always a very
tempting option um we would just take
back with the bishop and now we're going
to be very happy because we've kind of
undermined um White's menacing a center
and we're ready to play Knight to E7 and
castles so say if White Castle's here
the reason we may not want to go here um
we this is perfectly fine but then this
check becomes a little Annoying we kind
of have to retreat this bishop so I
would prefer to block with the Knight
and now no matter what white does we're
ready to Castle next
turn so um this would be a good way to
go about the position if they take on D6
we should be pretty happy we're ready to
Castle very quickly and again if we can
Castle on any of these gambits we're in
very good shape because we have the
material and white doesn't have much to
show for it if we can Castle so e takes
D6 is nothing to be afraid of so let's
look at uh Knight takes D5 this is
another way to take the Free Pawn and in
response to this we're just going to
keep developing this is why we play D5
is to open up this bishop so we want to
develop this bishop and we're developing
it bringing it off the back rank but
we're also attacking this Knight on E5
so this is a great move
um having uh two purposes and after
Bishop to E6 white has a few options
they can go Knight to say E3 um but then
we just kind of trade and things are
pretty simple they could play Queen to
F3 to defend D5 but we would just play
C6 and then once this Knight moves we
can actually grab this Pawn on D4 and
that's a very very important Pawn once
this Pawn Falls everything kind of
collapses for white so um black is in
very good shape after Bishop to E6 here
because we're kind of fighting back
we're developing our pieces and we're
creating our own threats white is not
the one having all the
fun so the best move after D5 here is
actually Bishop takes D5 so Bishop takes
D5 um can easily be kicked out with a
move like Bishop E6 because Bishop E6
so it unfortunately it's not as easy to
play but we can develop this Knight
which was undefended and at the same
time attack so it's the same idea of
developing and attacking one of White's
pieces but in this case instead of the
bishop it's the Knight doing
that so after Knight 8 to E7 um because
both of these Knights could technically
go here so we have to specify that it's
the E eighth rank Knight um after this
move we either has to move this bishop
or could also pin um this Knight you
wouldn't want to play a move like Queen
to F3 because then we would just take on
D5 and again be pretty happy with this
position after a move like C6 and taking
on
D4 so instead of Queen to F3 white kind
of has to again move the bishop or pin
it so after Bishop to
B3 if they move the bishop white still
has some good pressure on this diagonal
good control of the center but we can
fight back we can play Knight to F5 and
again this is the base of White's Pawn
chain if we can win this Pawn White's
structure begins to fall apart and we're
going to be in very good shape so Knight
to F5 is a very dangerous move can't
really Push It Forward because if they
push we would be able to take here
because this Pawn was defending that um
so Knight F5 is a difficult move to deal
with it's not easy to defend this pawn
and uh we should have good pressure
against White's strong Center and uh
still be able to Castle very quickly so
after Knight to F5 I believe black has a
great position and as well on his way to
winning the game so Bishop to G5 another
developing move um is probably a better
move because again it's doing two things
at once anytime we can develop and do
something else that's going to be a good
move so white is developing and dealing
with this Threat by pinning the Knight
so we can't take now because our Queen
would be
taken so after Bishop did G5 this pin's
really annoying we really want to get
out of this pin um so we actually just
play Queen to D7 so you might be asking
well why not play like H6 or something
like
because uh this bishop can't really go
back right it's that square is protected
and it looks like that just kind of gets
rid of this pin but white has this very
dangerous move Queen to F3 creating um
or countering our threat with a bigger
threat of Queen six
F7 so this would be a uh very annoying
move to face so we want to avoid that if
possible um so we play Queen D7 um
because after H6 we're still not
threatening this this bishop has to move
out of the way first so that gives him
time to play Move like Queen to
F3 but after Queen to D7 a move like
Queen F3 just doesn't work because we
could just take on
D5 so pretty complicated position you
know when you get into the weeds of it
but bottom line is our Knight is pinned
we get out of the pin so in this
position again Queen F3 just doesn't
really work we're just going to take D4
is very weak and we should be very happy
with that and then if we move like
Bishop to E4 again we want to find a
ways to attack the center so here we're
going to play the move Knight to F5 and
again it's very very difficult for white
to hold on to the strong Center we're
attacking this D4 Pawn twice and it's
only defended once so it's going to be
very difficult for white to do
anything um really the only legitimate
way to protect it would be to play like
Knight to E2 but that's retreating a
piece that's already developed that's
not a good move or a move that white
wants to
play and in response we can continue to
break down the center with a move like
C5 C5 is a very strong move because
again this is the base of the pawn chain
if we can take away that base take away
that concrete foundation the whole house
starts to fall apart E5 would be taken
um it's just no good so um the ideas
here just to kind of recap is we're not
going to be afraid to take this piece
and instead of going back to C6 we
actually want to go back to G6 where
it's not going to be attacked again and
then unfortunately we have to play this
move Knight to G8 but we're going to
counter back in the center with this
aggressive move D5 and after this move
we should be able to develop and Castle
relatively easily and hold on to our
extra piece so this is how to counter
the Halloween gambits with black comment
down below if you have any questions and
thank you for
watching